Hey, I'm here with Larry, and
he's been having a problem with
a webpage he's been working on.
I think this is a great opportunity to
both help Larry out with his problem and
to show you what version
control can be useful for.
>> Yeah, so,
I've been working on a website, and
it looks a lot different
than it did before.
There used to be a banner at the top.
And like the design looked
a lot better before.
>> Hm, so, what did it look like before?
>> I have an old version
saved on this tab.
>> Oh, yeah, I see.
It looks like you
changed the description.
>> Yeah, I filled it in.
>> Cool.
Did you change anything else?
>> I think I might have,
but I'm not sure.
>> Do you still have the HTML for
this version?
>> Yeah, I do.
>> Cool, so you could compare
the two and see what changed.
>> Okay, let's try it.
>> Now I want you to find the
differences between the two versions of
this HTML.
Go ahead and
find the lines that have changed,
then enter the line numbers in this box,
separated by commas.